hey friends it's Justine and today we
are here in the studio checking out
something that I have actually been very
interested in testing for a very long
time let me introduce you to the
remarkable 2 the ultimate notetaking
toolkit a huge thank you to remarkable
for partnering with me on this video
Let's unbox it and check it out so here
we have our remarkable two and we have
some accessories we've got a little
keyboard a premium leather book folio
and of course our marker plus remarkable
pen so first things first I think we
need to actually unbox the device it's
itself oh I love this packaging this
little embossed
logo and here it is we're presented with
a little welcome and the device oh my
good this is so light this is lighter
than like an actual
notebook okay like this might this might
look like a a peel or a sticker but no
this is actually this is it this is the
screen this is the display it is written
on the device like this is it's so cool
I mean it legit looks like a piece of
paper like this is so light it actually
feels like a stack of a few pages of
paper it says hold the power button to
get started okay well hold on let's open
up the rest of this
first quick start guide okay we're
definitely going to need that swipe left
to go to the next page right to go to
the previous long press actions okay and
inside here we we've got a oh look at
this nice USB
cable next up we've got our marker
plus ooh has a nice texture I like that
it also has a nice flat Edge there which
is a nice little grip okay here we go
hold the power button to get started
it's wild because I feel like there's so
much Tech now that it gets overwhelming
like when I'm on my phone or on my
computer I get so distracted that having
something like this can kind of reel in
my focus and not let me get distracted
with tons of other apps and music or
just whatever else this just will let me
write okay write sketch or scribble
below oh my goodness this is so like
this
feels this feels like
paper so here's our premium leather
black
folio I love that I can just slide this
right in and it's like an actual little
notebook so nice now we also have a
keyboard which is pretty exciting
especially for people who do a lot of
writing this is going to be
incredible look at this so fresh oh my
goodness
wow love
it oh my goodness this is super cool
pair with a remarkable Cloud ah yeah
let's do it okay pairing my device and
it is giving me a code to enter so now
that everything is all paired we're
continuing our setup and it is asking if
I'm left or right-handed love this okay
I am left-handed here's our tutorial
like this reminds me of just like the
old school OS like this is what my first
kind of computer experience sort of felt
like so this is kind of taking me back
to the day these six steps will show you
how to use remarkable will introduce you
to some ways of working record ideas
write sketch create new notebooks you
can also upload PDFs and ebooks V are
okay I love that categorize your work
using keywords such as on hold in
progress also take notes using typed
text love it okay so I'm going to do my
first quick sheet here it is oh my God
it's like
a
wa okay so I was going to I was going to
write something but now I just kind of
want to scribble like it feels so much
like paper the harder that you press
down the thicker the line this is so
great I love it I'm obsessed okay how do
I delete everything this was just a
test erase all well that was simple
let's see the different types of marker
styles that we have so we've got a
ballpoint pen flatliner pencil
mechanical pencil highlighter marker
paintbrush and a calligraphy pen okay
this is fun selection tools Circle your
content to rotate okay let's see oh that
works pretty fast too
so can I move it oh my gosh look at this
I'm just moving it around oh I'm having
so much fun this is like tricking my
mind because it feels like I'm writing
but yet I can select stuff what does
this do does that change it to
text paste what does that do it copied
what I wrote and then changed it to text
we're going to undo that because um I I
want to I want to save this forever cuz
it's beautiful so we're going to name
this and there it is just's notebook
this is cool look at all these different
templates that we have college legal
week planner this could change my life I
have needed something to just keep me
organized and it needed to be a piece of
tech but I didn't quite know what it was
and I think this might be exactly what
I've been looking for all my
[Music]
life so after some testing and getting
to know remarkable like I can see why so
many people love this product now
obviously the design is incredible and
it's lightweight it's so portable and it
has this clean minimalistic look to it
and this also extends into the user
interface it is extremely simple and
it's so intuitive it really is like a
digital notebook it has that analog
feeling of real paper but with none of
the drawbacks that come along with many
other digital devices and of course
coming from somebody who is so addicted
to technology being able to kind of take
a step back but still using technology
to kind of take me out of technology
does that even make any sense while this
is a digital device it doesn't feel
digital which is I think the coolest
part about it I think one of my favorite
Parts about writing on here so far is
when I normally write I write on blank
pieces of paper with markers and I write
huge letters like I like writing massive
so what's really fun is I can kind of
pair writing and drawing and like little
graphics with typed things and it's just
it's so fast and this has such a similar
feel to an actual marker I also like
that you can go in and change different
colors like you can go in and add like
some Grays which kind of just adds a
little fun to it it's also so easy to
swap this into the keyboard mode so I
feel like most likely I will probably
keep this keyboard folio on here and
it's just so nice like I can just fold
it up and down and go along my way I
have some crumbs on here crumbs Not
Included the other thing that I've
noticed unfortunately as I've been
getting older and because I've been
using technology and looking at screens
so much is eye fatigue and what I've
noticed about this it feels natural it
doesn't feel like you're looking at a
digital display it has kind of eased my
eye fatigue that I feel so often from
looking at my computer too much and with
this I have all of the added benefits of
a computer but with so much less of that
eye strain I also love that there's a
desktop and mobile app which lets you
tap into your work no matter where you
are I know I talked so much about
distractions but I feel like this is one
of the main reasons that I really love
this so much is when I'm using
remarkable there's no distractions from
whatever I'm working on and I spend a
lot of time writing planning out feuture
projects making outlines and scripts for
videos writing down different ideas
making to-do lists like you name it I'm
usually always doing that in either one
of two places my phone or my computer
don't get me wrong we all know that
those devices are convenient and there
is a time and place for all of them but
trying to focus and do deep work on your
phone can be pretty hard because of all
of the distractions that do come with
that notifications popping up alerts
about upcoming deadlines emails coming
in text messages notifications from all
of your favorite apps obviously you you
can just turn those off but even when
they're turned on like I still find
myself scrolling and being like Oh there
was a message that I didn't write back
to and you're in that environment and it
is just begging to take your attention
elsewhere like just one small swipe at
any time on your phone I'll be gone for
hours and I'll completely forget what it
was that I was even working on so that
is one of the reasons that I have
absolutely loved remarkable and it's
been so awesome to use and has all of
the convenience I of all of these
devices but without any of the
distraction so overall I've been super
impressed with this device now if you
want to learn more about remarkable or
pick up one for yourself or a loved one
I put a link in the description so
definitely check this out thank you guys
so much for watching let me know what
you guys think of this in the comments
below and make sure to like this video
And subscribe if you're not already and
with that my friends I will see you in
the next video bye